so now that we've combined pulley a
string to platform and washer as our
system we can now address our question
if we measure the acceleration of the
person what is the force that the person
pulls the rope down with well of course
that will just be the tension in the
string and with this simple system we
can now apply Newton's second law F
equals MA but recall we need some
directions so suppose we expect that the
acceleration of the other platform in
person is up so we'll choose a unit
vector J hat in the positive direction
and now the problem becomes tension one
three different tensions 3t one and
gravitational force minus MP + MW times
G now what is the mass that we have to
consider again what is the mass of our
system well the platform and the person
and we assume the pulley and the string
to we're massless so we have simply MP +
MW a and so we can now solve for the
tension in the string which is equal to
MP + MW times g plus a divided by three
and recall that this tension that the
string is pulling this is what we called
the force that the person of the string
on the person and by Newton's third law
that's also the on the washer that's
also the force that the washer applies
to string one so this was our goal it's
the force that the washer applies to
string one by the third law and so by
thinking about how to choose a system
what could be a very complicated
with lots of equations is simply one
equation